Find the volume of a tank whose
base has an area of 3x
squared plus 30x plus 5
square feet and whose
height is 8x minus 5.
So let me draw a potential
tank here.
Maybe it's a cylinder, so let
me draw a cylindrical tank
here, just like that.
It's supposed to be a cylinder,
and maybe if it was
transparent, you would see this
back side over there.
And these two are the same.
These are supposed to
be straight lines.
And the volume of a-- let me
just label it first. So the
area of the base, which is the
same as the area of the top
here or of the base here, the
area of that is 3x squared
plus 30x plus 5.
And they tell us the height
is 8x minus 5.
The height of this tank
And if you want to find the
volume of a three-dimensional
object like this, you just
multiply the area of the base
times the height.
So the volume is going to be the
area of the base, which is
3x squared plus 30x plus
5, times the height,
times 8x minus 5.
Now, to multiply something like
this out, it might seem
really complicated, but we once
again, we just have to do
the distributive property.
If you viewed this big thing in
pink here as just a number,
if this was like the number 7,
you'd just say, well, this is
going to be 7 times 8x minus 7
times 5 or minus 5 times 7.
You would just distribute
it out.
You would just multiply this
entire thing times each of the
terms. That's what the
distributive property tells us
when you first learned it.
So let's do that.
So it's going to be this entire
thing times 8x, or we
can view it as 8x times
this entire thing.
So 8x times this entire thing:
3x squared plus 30x plus 5,
minus 5 times the entire thing
again, or the entire thing
times minus 5.
So once again you get 3x squared
plus 30x plus 5.
And now we just multiply
these out.
We just distribute out the 8x
over this whole thing and we
distribute out the negative
5 over that whole thing.
So then we get 8x times
3x squared is 24x
to the third power.
8x times 30x is what?
That's 240x squared, so
plus 240x squared.
8x times 5 is plus 40x.
And then we multiply this
negative 5 out.
Negative 5 times 3x squared
is negative 15x squared.
Negative 5 times 30x
is negative 150x.
And then negative 5 times
5 is negative 25.
And then we just have to
simplify it from here.
So we only have one third-degree
term, one thing
that has an x to the
third in it.
We have this term right here,
so we'll write that
as 24x to the third.
And then what are our
x squared terms?
We have 240x squared
minus 15x squared.
So what's two 240 minus 15?
It's 225x squared.
So plus 225x squared.
That's adding that term to that
term right over there.
And then we have
40x minus 150x.
That would be negative 110x.
And then finally we have just
this negative 25 out here.
That's the only constant term.
And we're done!
We found the volume
of the tank.
It's given by this polynomial
expression right here.
So this right here is the
volume of the tank.
It's equal to 24x to the
third plus 225x squared
minus 110x minus 25.